i think we can all agree that this was a
very stressful week for america
in fact there are a lot of things in
life that are stressful and whenever
life is stressing me out
i like to take a moment and gaze at the
stars
whoa a shooting star
wow i think i'll make a wish on it
i wish i could stop climate change
whoa i wish everyone in the world could
just get along with everyone
except nicki minaj because i love it
when she has beef
oh whoa another shooting star whoa
i wish i could fly any airline
for free regardless of my miles
[Music]
i wish a mother would
whoa i wish number two pencils were
called that because
they go number two
whoa another shooting star wow i wish
simone biles would just admit that we
are best friends
i wish the www at the beginning of a web
address stood for
whoa
i wish there was an elaborate system of
hidden tampons around new york city so
whenever i need one there's one nearby
wow i wish jurassic park was real
but instead of dinosaurs it's unicorns
but they still try to kill you
oh another wish i wish tequila had
calcium i wish
i could tell the difference between
laura linney and laura dern
oh i wish spiders wore
tap shoes that way when you hear one
coming you'll be like
is that savion glover no it's just a
spider
oh i wish there was a vaccine
for polio what there is
oh yay my wish came true that was
exciting can you believe all those
shooting stars came through here
sure you never know what's gonna happen
[Music]
you